ciao ragazzi dell del cielo piccoli
triangolini di gran nachos bayelsa por
crostatine che cadono sempre verso
giusto
volevo fare per questa puntata di cucina
buttata una cosa che ho sempre fatto e
come sempre venuta da grammer ha scritto
il karmapa fare a cagare anche stavolta
perfetto dicevo ho trovato una cosa
assurda introvabile e questa
dell'introvabile lievito di birra un
prodotto che l'hanno già fatta di
italians annegato nella sua intera vita
ma che con questo momento di isolamento
o andato a ruba lievito fresco fresco
come sapete non sono un'amante lieviti
sono un amante dei gran gilbert fumo che
non mi pagano giorno ma di quali un
giorno solo sponsor me lo sento però mi
sono detto perché non usarli li ho
comprati così perché ho pensato è
un'occasione anche solo per rivenderne
ed i suoi bei a 600 euro
questi bene chi devono essere in qualche
modo utilizzate ho passato un po di
giorni a studiarli e a fissarli sperando
che gli evitassero ma non lo hanno fatto
questo vuol dire che hanno bisogno di
farina acqua
non so cosa sto dicendo quello che
volevo dire che ho finalmente trovato la
ricetta e questi panetti le rondelle
prenderà seguiamo i no secchi rondelli
rondelle dell'azienda lesaffre vabbè chi
sono io per giudicare
ho deciso di utilizzare le rondelle
dell'azienda lesaffre per creare un
piatto che celebri secondo me il modo in
cui noi italiani abbiamo reagito a
questo isolamento
qualcuno potrebbe dire sbattendo la
testa al muro cantando canzoni sui
balconi e masturbandosi forsennatamente
ma no anche in un altro modo lo abbiamo
passato con dignità facendo vedere che
popolo siamo un po quello che sta
avvenendo un pochino abbandonato in
questo periodo ma che comunque va avanti
a testa alta ed è per questo che voglio
celebrare la nostra bandiera con un
piatto che ci rappresenta al cento per
cento la pizza margherita e la pizza a
me di base sembrerà un'opinione
pericolose ma a me non mi dice un kart
ma comunque lo farò mi sono messo a
cercare un po ovunque su internet perché
quello che vorrei fare è per una volta
una pizza che non faccia cagare c'è una
pizza che sia buona anche
e se mi richiederà un po di tempo anzi
mi piace quasi l'idea di dover aspettare
un po di tempo per fare una pizza che
sia veramente buona soffice quelle cose
lì un po croccante va beh insomma avete
capito ho chiamato mio fratello gian
luigi anzi proviamo adesso perché
mandato dei segreti dei segreti
segretissimi gianluigi ormai grazie a
questa quarantenne diventato veramente
un abile panificatore potrebbe aprirsi
un panificio domani ogni giorno ci manda
delle foto su whatsapp nel gruppo di
tutta la famiglia delle sue pagnotte ma
e ferro non mi vuole bene
chiamiamo alla ragazza una ragazza è
sempre stata più seria del mio fratello
giorgio b b senti sto cercando di
mettermi in contatto con quella me nel
mio fratello ancora mer di stato c'era
giallo sto girando un video sappi che ti
sto per mostrare in video gianluigi
saluta il video bimbi fai vedere che
cosa sta facendo
come potete per vedere gli stage a
quando le mani e adesso andrò a pulire
questi sei campbell in queste tele passa
al bollore facciata che non cala mai le
gambe ma se andato fino in sicilia a
prenderlo battuta pescina possiamo far
vedere intanto il pane che stavi
preparando una zozzeria è venuto nome
cioè oggi non è stata un po gen e andata
quindi ma come mai oggi andata così
abbiamo la tagliare insieme secondo
mette però è scoperto calcio e calci non
ho schiacciato qualche figuraccia non è
come aver come avevo previsto credimi
effetto
sì è vero no no sì sì sì sì a zuma
toward è vero è un attore senti io da te
ho preso un pochino di dritte
mi sa che le dimenticherò queste dritte
una delle due dritte quella di mettere
un pentolino con dell'acqua in forno
giusto sarà fatto che verrà sapere se
viene altezza ammette il tuo padre
io nel dubbio mi sono anche visto un
video in questo caso è peak napoletana
fatta in casa i salvatori e lionello
quindi grazie saltatore si terrà bene
comunque ringraziare mio fratello che
non faccia rimanere male ma dopo quel
pane che ho visto non mi fido più del
mio stesso sangue per fare la pizza
napoletana fatta in casa avremo bisogno
di importantissimo ragazzi scusate prima
di dirvi quali sono gli ingredienti
prendete una fetta di pane e nutella e
mi potevo aiutarla alcune venuta fame
infine come dicevo per fare la pizza un
po bisogno di 10 grammi di sale e acqua
prima di iniziare debba stare tutto
riaprite una guerra con apre in maniera
graziata inizia tra bugiarda se vederci
a faber
[Musica]
prendete una ciotola e a questo punto ci
aggiungiamo l'acqua bene come al suo
interno 340 mm apriamo il nostro sacro
panetto di burro se magari il lievito 3
grammi per g 4 ci stanno sbriciolando
un'acqua a questo punto mentre vi
lievitano i polpastrelli prendiamo la
farina e aggiungiamo 500 grammi ma è
troppo ha detto 500 guardare per credere
500 grammi non sono 5mila le virgole e
mezzo a questo punto con molto allo
chance prendiamo la farina prendiamo la
nostra terza la fiera bolla così ma
questo gol non gol
boh e versiamo c la farina scala canucks
a cala cala cala cucchiaio e giriamo
eliminiamo la rimaniamo la rimaniamo la
semina la dott.sa orari minatori sono
con la testa contro questo sportello non
so se lo vedete ma quando per metà
aggiungiamo il sale 10 grammi cercarla
caracas passato dieci grammi fermare c'è
un'esplosione oceania e mentre creiamo
la morte dei vostri venire abbiamo la
canzone
nana nana nana nana nonna e per la
realtà con i nipoti figli
amanda
[Musica]
no io ci metto le mani ai ragazzi in
venezuela che zone maggiormente mi
faccio una pizza non doveva andare così
le dosi non sono giustissime c'era
troppa acqua dove la farina si fa in
questi casi ci ho messo un po più di
farina mia speranza di salvare almeno le
mani forse non è che non lo impastata
abbastanza ci sono una cosa pulisco il
piano a di lavoro o il potere apparente
della farina globale visto inglobando la
molletta non mi sto provando la farina
toglietevi dal capo è un tutt'uno con la
mia mano allora dopo aver pulito le mani
aver aggiunto un po di farina non troppa
è ancora leggermente al pc cosina ma
credo ci stia noi la copriamo con un
panno e aspettiamo cinque minuti in
questi cinque minuti potete mettere a
posto il sale potete maledire il momento
è venuta un'idea così del cups avete un
sacco di opzioni personalmente io
preferisco rimettere a posto il delirio
e tutti gli errori che ho commesso
devo farmi capire come si toglie le
questure sui fornelli
mamma mia del nervoso e la cosa più
tosta da togliere dai ripiani di
grattare sto me nuovo i cinque minuti
più lunghi della mia intera esistenza
con la plastica che cosa andremo a fare
il non ha senso più senso di bobin
guardian leviosa cioè avada kedavra
hanno più senso proprio eccolo qui
finalmente vice priamo di nuovo questo
caso lo prendiamo vedi non sporcare e
andiamo a creare le pieghe di forza così
lo paghiamo su punto ributtiamo dentro
ma la domanda è secca sulle pieghe di
forza cosa sono le pieghe di forza degli
impasti a cosa servono di berlo
biologico puntoit le pieghe servono
principalmente per i seguenti motivi
migliorare la struttura della maniglia
glutin ica rinforzare l'impasto per
permettergli di crescere in altezza
agevolare la lievitazione facendo uscire
i gas già prodotti da giocatori e
proseguiamo strofinaccio piazziamo sopra
piatto mettiamo sopra a questo punto
sbattiamo in frigo tale 10 ago la manina
chiudete io farò lievitare il mio
impasto 12 ore in frigo prima
limitazione perché voglio fare i due
perché poco mi sento quatto quatto na
cifra mi sento proprio da michele a
napoli ci vede in modo mattina vi chiedo
scusa per la mia faccia perché vorrei
mettermi la sveglia e subito partire a
riprendere potrò essere immondo
anzi molto probabilmente sono il mondo
quindi se siete sensibili o se avete
vicino a voi qualcuno di particolarmente
sensibili e coprite gli occhi guardate
le prossime clip giudicate voi se è
giusto o no che continuino la visione
che tra poco bongiorno se lo so la
faccia gonfia funzionato sono
completamente rincoglionito prendiamo la
bilancia
accendiamo a prendere adesso non ho
voluto e perché no no no no
questo facendo usiamo questo quadro non
sono attaccare scusatemi non so cosa sto
facendo
chiudiamo un coltello ma premuto rexy
siamo dei panetti
forse michele farina nelle mani le varie
infarinate dobbiamo fare dei panetti da
250 grammi è normale ragazzi che sia
così appiccicosa ma così tanto a te ci
cosa che sta cosa non la fate mattina mi
sento di popolari che denota la volontà
usare un per cento del suo cervello
esperimento fallito usate nebbiosa di
attivato sempre questa pasta si sta
staccando fuori io forse l'olio perduto
mentenere ragazzi qualcuno sa come
funziona esattamente questo procedimento
cosa ho sbagliato ma non ho parole
favore su 250 e un po di vino
no no
io questo l'unico paletto però
infarinato esternamente gli altri non so
cosa succederà dobbiamo prendere la
teglia coprirla con uno strofinaccio
aprile forno accendere solo la luce
infine la teglia dentro e proseguire la
lievitazione per almeno altre 4 ore
invece vediamo fra quattro ore e spero
che lo spettacolo sia migliore ragazzi
temo che ormai questo commento sia già
stato scritto qua sotto
ho fatto un errore parlando con un mio
amico mi ha spiegato che tutti i
procedimenti che io ho fatto nei quali
la pizza lì si appiccicava dunque
procedimenti avrei dovuto utilizzare
l'olio quindi o le aree leggermente le
tele o le aree leggermente la bull come
cavolo si chiama l'insalatiera e le mani
al fine di non far pizzicare la pizza
temo che ci saranno un sacco di commenti
riguardo questa cosa qua sotto al
problema è che adesso io non so in che
modo riuscivano a staccare andiamo a
vedere che è successo e tanto andando
ott io no no ti prego no ma che è
successo una cosa ma perché cerchiamo di
salvare la situa la cosa prisca tema il
forno statico a 250 gradi che è massima
potenza e quindi se diamo scusate
l'inquadratura adesso bisognerà usare la
farina meglio questa teglia come faccio
marina farina farina usiamo né un botto
perché ho fatto abbastanza a casini in
questa dovrebbe praticamente salvarmi un
po il culo come faccio
ok sopra perché muove così praticamente
tu dovresti non essere super allungabile
il che torna indietro
l'impasto è elastici simo se posso dire
la mia che facciamo io o la pizza qui
bellissima mi piace un sacco st rizza no
se rotta era bellissima nel frattempo
tolgo vani
ok ho deciso di fare questa cosa questa
pizza line fornero ma voglio provare a
farne una in padella
ho fatto gialli pizzette in padella
vorrei provare a farne una grossa in
padella sono gasatissimo da quest'idea
che ho avuto potrebbe andare bene o
malissimo chi lo sa vediamo pizza in
padella pizza sorveglia prendiamo del
pomodoro iniziamo a metterci avremmo
dovuto stenderla meglio sono d'accordo
con voi e mi fa capire che tentano non
si può improvvisare pizzaiolo io passo
intanto emettere il pomodoro anche
questa in se stessa merito mozzarella
che ho da sempre taglio con le forbici
non so perché non so se la cosa si fa lo
faccio solo io se l'ha fatto molte
persone ma io trovo che taglierà un
serio le forbici sta nell'aver pizza
ovviamente in tutto questo è arrivato il
momento di condividere una cosa che qui
potrò ricevere un po di critiche io
italiano al cento per cento comunque non
sono un fan della pizza e tra tutte
quante pizze vero pure che la margherita
è proprio quella che
non mi attira al mondo a parto con un
passato da amante la capricciosa dove mi
sono fatto un bel periodo di boscaiola
norma buonissima ma ultimamente raga una
pizza che ho sempre criticato e che
invece ho scoperto è la diavola mai
amata ultimamente quel ficcanti almeno
alla nostra pizza preferita
sono curioso se si capisce un sacco che
la versione davanti della pizza che
ordina e poi mi piacciono anche dello
tipo di peak è un po gourmet quelli un
po particolari quelli che per molti non
sono nemmeno pizza aggiungiamo la
mozzarella cioè con la mozzarella io
abbondo sappiate don abbondio è una cosa
che chiederò anche da bambino dal piano
tiene nascono esperimento non ho nemmeno
visto mezzo tutorial su come fare per il
sen padella alce nero fuoco copriamo
abbiamo il forno usare per questo
aquilotto bisogno di tutte e due le mani
perché voglio mettere solamente la carta
da forno bella credo di aver fatto
qualche piccolo errore entra niente non
lanciata nel forno perché mi sta
funzionando ora che dicono comunque di
tenerla sui quattro minuti cinque minuti
diventano così e non verrà bellissima
questa qua ora gava lascia andare
vedremo che succede questo qui bisogna
comprarne un altro dei che ha per quanto
sono disperato da bruxelles che bella
che sei fatta mi sa che è fatta per
minuti ma come volete ma che sia pronto
anche l'altra al volo con lei in filo
d'olio a crudo
mamma mia ho esagerato è quel giusto
basilico e tu sei andata anche quella in
forno è andata filetto d'olio a crudo
vino inserisce ma essere un pochino più
morigerati
ok queste sono loro due un pochino chi
vincente siamo arrivati al momento
dell'assaggio abbiamo qui la teglia e la
patella vediamo quali 22 vince e se ci
stanno delle differenze tra una pizza a
forno e una pizza in padella
detto ciò che procede all'assaggio vi
chiedo sempre lo stesso a favore di
iscrivervi a questo canale di lasciare
un pollice in su per il visto che dopo
due pixel bagno
ne risentirà invece con un bel pollice
su per il riusciremo a contenere il
disagio dito ciò fatemi sapere quali
altre ricette sfide esperimenti vorreste
vedere in cucina io mi sono già rotto le
p e fare questi tre ambo li voglio
lanciare la cottura sembrerebbe perfetta
eppure mi sembrava averla tenuta troppo
poco previdentemente con fatto che
lievitato così tanto mi sono reso conto
che è sottilissima la pizza ma stesso
perché c'era il cornicione leggerissimo
con tutti i forellini tutto quanto è
buono ma leggerissimo questa impressione
quando in padella sarà sicuramente
diversa è infatti sotto e più croccante
mi dispiace il fatto che lo sia perché
vengono un po da ravizza romana che è la
storia durissima ha detto ma c'è anche
quella ma anche napoletano a me non fa
impazzire me piace una via di mezzo il
sotto un po croccantino ma un po altino
e ho un problema con tutte le pizze
anche o sembra rete magni in pezzo le
corteccia ma anche quelli di troppo
moscia quella che davanti catena e
quindi devi ripiegare dentro non lo so
mi mette ansia con la roba di uno si
sente che ha cotto al vapore un attore
chiudendo il tappo sopra mozzarella si è
sciolta molto di più appeal antissime
viva preferisco allora vince per quanto
riguarda il sopra un condimento come si
sono amalgamati voli ingredienti in una
padella assolutamente non è quanto
riguarda la pizza in sé e la resa poi
dell'impasto finale al forno quindi e
tamburi in permesso
non è superiore a quello sbagliato
qualcosa in padella ma il forno è
superiore perché non si è sciolto forse
avendo aspettato di più spiegato